before Elon Musk or Tesla management
unveils a product it is usually
enveloped in rumors speculation and
increased hype just like their Model S
plaid and just before they unveiled a
humanoid robot Elon Musk is not slowing
down as his mind is filled with the
craziest ideas and today we will tell
you all about another product from Tesla
that has been Gathering serious momentum
the model pie let's find out why it's
genius body so what is the model pie
it's a rumored smartphone from Tesla
that has been causing chaos on the
internet especially on YouTube with
major phone manufacturers like Apple
Samsung and Huawei making very similar
phones year in and year out the
smartphone world has been begging for
something refreshing to Grace their
palms as these days it seems like there
is nothing to get excited about when it
comes to smartphones only bigger cameras
or bigger screens or at best cool
designs with musk himself making
comments about how phones don't even
make people happy anymore well slightly
they based on his Twitter experience it
seems like he is giving a hint to the
release of the company's next
Blockbuster product and with his track
record of disrupting every industry if
he dips his fingers in our imaginations
only limits the possibilities of what
features would be in the Tesla Model pie
come on this man makes robots and will
soon send people to Mars so when rumors
started circulating especially from a
video by the YouTube channel ADR Studio
designs of a Tesla phone that would
disrupt the industry were revealed even
though the supposed Source video
indicated it was only ideas from a
designer it didn't stop videos of the
Tesla PI from spreading like wildfire
Tesla is an automobile company so why
would it want to make phones while Tesla
is largely popular because of its
electric vehicles the company isn't only
about that they also make several not so
popular products like solar panels
powerwalls and of course batteries and
with a CEO like musk you can imagine
anything could happen at work the man
just acquired Twitter out of the blue a
pun intended it makes sense that he
would want to produce a one-of-a-kind
phone capable of doing almost everything
just like his company's cars before you
get too excited though please remember
that for now the model pie is still a
concept so don't expect to see one
tomorrow or next year but it doesn't
spoil the fun at least you'd know what
your phone is missing so without further
Ado let's get right into some of the
features of this phone Tesla is well
known for the Innovative features that
it frequently includes in its new models
some Tesla vehicles for example include
a defense mode that Shields users
against bioweapon attacks there's also a
virtually impregnable exoskeleton on the
Tesla cyber truck talking about
exteriors let's begin with the exterior
of the Pie Design in most videos the
Tesla Pi looks a lot like your modern
smartphone resembling the iPhone 12 in
more ways than one however the pie comes
with four cameras arranged in a square
and placed at the uppermost Center
rather than in a corner as we see in
most phones hmm groovy experts speculate
that with musk being a battery guy the
back camera orientation allows for a
large battery pack meaning longer life
there are also speculations that the
four cameras would serve more purpose
than pictures if Tesla's EVS are
anything to go by the cameras may act as
sensors for a feature we'll talk about
later in this video so stick around to
the end as you don't want to miss it the
cameras though would be able to perform
their basic function of taking brilliant
pictures in a very bright environment
and even under the night sky solar
charging still on the exterior of the
model Pi Tesla is well known for
producing solar panels so it's not out
of the question that the company would
include some form of solar charging
feature in the forthcoming phone
although they would have to figure out
an efficient way to do this because most
people keep their phones tucked away in
their pockets when they're not using
them however if Tesla can pull this off
it would be revolutionary at best you
get a phone that rarely needs an
external charging cable as it never runs
out of battery fitting solar panels in a
phone sounds like like a feat that Tesla
can achieve and we can't wait to see it
happen sat internet aside from being the
CEO of Tesla and the boring company musk
is also the CEO of SpaceX a company that
has launched its integrated satellite
internet service starlink according to
certain rumors Tesla may include
Starling Services inside this phone the
main difficulty with this is the massive
antennas that such a service needs this
would be quite tough for Tesla to
include in a phone unless they want this
looking like something from the 1950s
but there's a chance that starlink would
work with the phone in regions where
starlink is already in place they could
even install the antennas in their
vehicles which would then be connected
and utilized with the PI phone imagine
what you could do with that internet
speed the world would basically be in
your palms car control Tesla has already
released an iPhone and Android app that
allows users to operate their Tesla
vehicles with just their mobile devices
the software allows consumers to lock or
unlock their automobile start or stop
the engine and even locate the vehicle
the app may be completely integrated
into the Python's OS allowing for
operation through external buttons this
is a plausible feature we may expect to
see it if the Tesla phone is produced
Tesla might even provide some extra
functions in the app or software for
Tesla customers for example an AI
chauffeur or Robo taxi which musk has
already teased in past interviews mining
musk has previously spoken about
cryptocurrency and is a Dogecoin
investor so this shouldn't surprise you
according to some speculations the Tesla
phone might have Bitcoin mining gear
however we feel this is a bit of a
stretch because mining Bitcoin demands a
lot of power mining computers are
incredibly powerful and have
characteristics that differ from those
we use today while Bitcoin is the most
popular cryptocurrency and musk is
believed to like Dogecoin there is
suspicion that Tesla's phone may mine a
new coin called Mars coin which musk has
mentioned on Twitter some important
Hardware must be created for this to
work properly however it is still within
the company's grasp especially with its
tenacious CEO mind control musk owns
another firm called neuralink the
company's goal is to establish a
seamless interface between computers and
the human brain allowing people to
control computers just by thinking about
them a neuralink app is already in the
works allowing us to control our phones
keyboards and other devices straight
from our minds as a result the neuralink
app might be introduced to the Tesla
phone in a new manner with greater
integration and focus however the app is
still in the works we don't expect
neuralink to be ready for integration on
our phones until at least the second
part of 2025. this is where the other
feature of the cameras comes in we
believe the cameras on the pi would
function as sensors for the neural link
system the cameras would also help the
Tesla AI take in information from its
environment even if it may seem
unrealistic or too far-fetched neurolink
has already provided a sneak peek of
what it will be like to play games using
the human mind neuralink showed a monkey
playing mind pong with nothing but his
mind in a YouTube video playing the game
involves only visualizing hand gestures
the monkey could perform with greater
accuracy thanks to this technique
hitting the ball continuously and at
will it goes without saying that Gamers
won't be blaming malfunctioning
controllers anymore historically humans
have been prevented from accurately
communicating with their devices through
physical Hardware interfaces bmis might
however remove that restriction and
quite literally make man one with the
machine musk asserted that cutting-edge
brain implants from neuralink might soon
treat various illnesses from simple
memory loss to blindness and severe
brain injuries neurolink must clear
several moral and legal obstacles before
realizing its objectives particularly
because its contentious tests have led
some medical professionals to express
grave concern price the price of the pie
is yet to be released however based on
its features it is expected to be pricey
Tesla isn't renowned for being cheap and
we don't expect that to change with the
release of a smartphone if we were to
guess we expect it to be around twelve
hundred dollars or more profits almost
everyone today relies totally on cell
phones in their everyday lives China has
the largest smartphone market with over
911 million users as of 2021 India
ranked second with 439 million users
followed by the United States with 270
million users due to its massive user
base China is critical to the success of
major smartphone makers such as Samsung
apple and Huawei according to research
China has the world's shortest phone
replacement cycle this suggests that
Chinese smartphone buyers want to buy a
new handset as soon as possible if it
has excellent reviews and competitive
pricing according to Trend Force the
covid-19 outbreak had a significant
impact on the global smartphone industry
which had its lowest sales in four years
in contrast to their sales in 2019
smartphone companies only sold 1.25
billion devices in 2019 according to
Trend Force the smartphone market is
expected to make a substantial return by
the end of 2022 taking Replacements
demand and support into consideration
the smartphone market is expected to
sell more than 1.36 billion devices this
would result in a nine percent increase
and where there is money to be made
there is Tesla top smartphone makers
such as Apple and Samsung May one day
cease to exist or be successful as a
result of the model Pi's launch who
knows the smartphone market is about to
get a much needed breath of fresh air
thanks to Elon musk's impending
announcement of the model Pi several
smartphone companies have announced new
models and modified previous features in
recent years Elon has been working on
expanding the Tesla ecosystem which
includes gigafactories energy generation
and storage electric vehicles and SpaceX
the market for Tesla's past products
like its Vehicles would benefit and many
Tesla car customers May acquire the next
smartphone given the qualities of the
smartphone it's also possible that the
reverse May account and customers who
buy the smartphone would buy the
company's electric vehicles enjoyed this
video here are some more exciting videos
for you